[Music]
over the past two decades startups have
changed the world multi-billion dollar
companies like Google Facebook and uber
have shown the transformative power of
entrepreneurship today innovators dream
of their idea becoming the next big
thing but the odds are stacked against
them in America alone 80% of startups
will fail founding a startup isn't for
everyone
otherwise everyone would be doing it in
start-up hubs around the world young
entrepreneurs are desperate to prove
they have what it takes to succeed but
what does it really take to survive in
the hub
this is janosh Amstutz we want to do two
takes of that a former commodities
trader he's given up her six-figure
salary and a comfortable life in
Switzerland to try and make it as an
entrepreneur in London would you like to
stand here that way I'm out of the
spotlight this is our first professional
project that's very exciting today yeah
no she's directing his first photo shoot
that lighting looks great but it's not
the world of fashion where he hopes to
strike it rich so we'll have her as a
hologram in the real world it's the
world of augmented reality where janosh
believes he could revolutionize the way
that humans communicate are you trying
to reach an audience in a way that's
different or engaging well with our
technology we can bring you to them
anywhere anytime into their surroundings
Janusz is big idea is hollow me an
augmented reality application designed
to beam hologram like images through a
mobile phone and ultimately to supplant
video calling or even face-to-face
meetings why be here or there when you
could be everywhere all right let's do
one more but yeah no she's plans for
world domination begin in front of a
green screen in southeast London filming
images his software can then cut out and
project into any environment fantastic
[Music]
follow me is one of half a million
companies to start up in Britain every
year the nation's capital is a leading
hub of innovation inspiration and
creative energy in London and in cities
worldwide it's the age of the
entrepreneur startups are championed by
governments who see them as key to
building a dynamic economy
but the competition is cutthroat to
succeed you've got to really believe in
your product it's not a good idea to put
high-end fashion next to garbage counts
a week on from the photoshoot yeah no
she's footage is ready to test the
virtual catwalk on the street anywhere
on demand this is extremely exciting for
fashion retailers as a new way to
showcase their wares
there's my height and there's the dress
the blood sweat and tears that we put
into this project are really starting to
pay off and that's very exciting for me
I don't know where to look now you reach
a milestone er then what's the next step
where do we go from here how do we get
bigger how do we grow faster how do we
become more exciting for the world
smartphone technology has reached the
place where our tech is fully possible
and applicable to everybody
the rise of the smartphone has brought a
wave of global startup successes and
inspired endless possibilities for new
products with the proliferation of
digital technology and digital services
it's become easier than ever to set up a
business and to gamble everything on
having the next big idea
[Music]
San Paolo Brazil the most populous mega
city in the southern hemisphere and
another thriving startup hub Sandro and
Isabel were childhood sweethearts
they've been together for 17 years had
two children and now are trying to build
a business together for a year and a
half
Sandro and Isabel ran that company med
room from their front room traveling
through the same three phases swimming
cobain by the way two months ago the
couple took the big decision to rent
office space for their growing
professional family now they share a
workplace with dozens of other startups
all trying to make it in Brazil's
growing medical technology industry
[Music]
here they can encourage commiserate and
advised and Sandro can share his own
vision of success
with 18 years experience working in the
video gaming industry
Sandra saw the potential of virtual
reality earlier than many Sandra spotted
a gap in the market using VR to help
train medical professionals little to
nothing please publish it in Brazil one
in every 20 patients will experience
medical error
my name is Parvati um I had some
consider a Vanunu Mary Jo's match was no
Sun Blasio my staff is no moldings most
brass muslims devdays technology today
Vinicius goose mow the company's head of
marketing is at the Albert Einstein
Medical University to test out med rooms
product with some of the people who
probably need it the most medical
students 42% of failed entrepreneurs
cite a lack of demand for their
company's demise so it's crucial for
startups like med room to establish
whether their idea is a viable product
and not just an expensive toy SIV to
come on dude mister if anyone
he's vivillon I mean questions in
between doing right now this prototype
may lack the cutting edge but the
response from the products likely users
is encouraging cambered Instagram como
se
I mean she's giant ranked wanted to
conquer blue hair was a cinch must
convince my stripper odd that we will be
a second cuz I bring Jesus face MIDI
monstrous sound problems alone is a key
dodge the Akatsuki for your success
nós temos prepare the hounds dois três
mazes conseguimos computer primera vez
Nokomis algunas product monitor his
messages about guru virus Berg's virus
problemas
yeah garage chicken cig um fish back to
achieve huge concern over gibberish
comes to give us the optimum status
online companies else anonymous primero
change package targeting Brazil's
universities to kick off sales of their
product appears to be paying off
whilst mad room may have found its
market back in London janosh is just
trying to find a cab I don't have a
bottomless pit of money so for me the
financial pressure on the company is
quite strong hello
we have probably until the end of the
year to find financing
he's embarking on a quest that is a rite
of passage for thousands of
entrepreneurs in Europe's biggest
startup hub the search for investment
80% of startups in the UK are initially
self-funded as they work towards the
moment their big idea is convincing
enough to snare a major investor but
some have to make that move whether
they're ready or not please give me six
hundred thousand pounds I really don't
know how to convince someone how to give
me six hundred thousand pounds no one's
ever given me six hundred thousand
pounds before so maybe I'm doing it
wrong but we'll see in the first six
months of 2017 venture capitalists
pumped more than 1.1 billion pounds into
london's tech sector but only two
companies in every thousand managed to
get their hands on those funds morning
janosh has landed a meeting with an
investment firm that specializes in tech
startups Chris Haley and his partner
Corey vu receive over 100 pitches every
month
janosh has just weeks before he runs out
of cash tell us a little bit about
yourself and follow me and where the tax
at and give us the story I'm Swiss but I
grew up in Australia so my English is
relatively okay and understandable to
convince these investors entrepreneurs
like janosh need to know their business
plan back to front
so tell us a bit more about the funding
and how much you looking for I'm looking
for say four thousand pounds and the
figures better be rock solid because in
this room there's nowhere to hide you're
projecting monthly sales of 30,000 yeah
pretty much right off the bat yeah do
you have a qualified pipeline that
verifies that amount I can show you one
I have a in the past three weeks
well that's so you've got 20,000 for
next month
yep it's gonna take you more than a
month I suspect to reach that so I
assume you have been selling up to this
point we haven't started with what's the
timeline for the funding process
you mean you stopped people now when you
need it but now it looks like he's
planning October October been and I'm
being realistic a bit tight yeah no
she's dreams are in danger of remaining
just that if he can't convince these
tech savvy investors that his product is
worth backing one of the biggest
problems with holography is that it's
very hard to do the whole Star Trek
holiday thing how much depth of field is
captured in your day off so I think yeah
please do I'm gonna probably project it
there okay
well without technology we can bring you
to come anyway any time so it's it's
kind of hard to tell that he's only two
leaving because of because of the
quality of quality of holograms mm-hmm
we can also simply simulate shadows
which helps for a moving a moving person
we put fake shadows on the Holograms for
yeah for we have a dancer as well but
she needs a bit more space than in here
yeah it is shadowing but I don't play
shy they won the screams yeah chattering
yeah she is floating yes yes exactly
yeah yeah so that's that's the tech
we're pursuing I showed the investors an
old demo by accident what they saw was
actually an old version of a technology
which is why I didn't show them for too
long because I didn't want them to see
the the errors that we had in it but I
think they were still impressed which is
a good sign
janosh faces an anxious wait to see
whether the old demo was impressive
enough
[Music]
at the med room office in San Paolo
Sandro is putting a brave face on things
keeping the team happy is vital because
the one thing every startup is
guaranteed to face is a setback as you
prepare all the to watch more maize an
osprey minister also in Campinas to the
4-cylinder perf a system known as the
browser I just go for the moustaches
the pain is cassava in fast-moving
startup hubs like San Paolo adaptability
is crucial for any would-be entrepreneur
a new day a new opportunity med room has
been given a chance to present its
vision of the future to big health
industry players but it means taking
another gamble by racing to finish a new
more impressive version of its virtual
reality software they work on late into
the night with hours to go to the
presentation Sandro and the team are
finally done but the new software is yet
to be tested
the next morning Sandro is nowhere to be
seen
Sandro Norah Cosentino a gelatinous
catalpa so I know it's Allah with
internal surveillance problems represent
astonishing I wish
nós temos madam an American city has a
vase problem in the next room
representatives of Brazil's leading med
tech firms are gathered to discuss the
future of health technology thinks I
think the pieces are here totally listen
leave the disdain to those in places on
Zylstra Bali the pace med room is one of
only three startups invited to demo
their products after the meeting it's an
amazing networking opportunity which
they're about to blow Vinicius has less
than an hour to download install and
test the new software before the meeting
breaks up on those her premier - no
interesting three minutes follow mark
where's professor coke where's the key
and if a local director fate
so the NEBOSH a god thing
native African with my on a frigid
winters in places you guys I take for
the meeting of industry players is about
to end sync represent plants
Sandra taco hand abraca we know ecology
that back up
they make it with moments to spare and
so finally does their best salesman
Sandro
today's autism I am the top of stupid on
they had my age cause of you I'm saving
for us also because I found out
those claims cases resolve calamita to
the solidedge talk about toys even once
per channels compare myself yeah it was
a nice ecology in terms of you know
sometimes just getting through the day
can be chalked up as a win for a weary
entrepreneur
[Music]
eight weeks after pitching hallo me to
the venture capitalists janosh has yet
to hear from them so he's been stepping
up his search for paying customers we
gotta get that contract signed off as
well cool alright this might not seem
like the obvious place to find them but
today the British Museum is hosting a
digital design event and janosh has I
had an opportunity it's very
nerve-wracking to be able to show my
tech for the first time he wants to show
big retail firms what they could do with
his product which is why he's been
photographing fashion models it's part
of a collaboration with fashion label
Rick so demonstrating how hollow me can
bring merchandise off the shelf and into
the room
janosh is counting on this kind of
commercial application to start driving
sales we use augmented reality to
display them so cool that's pretty
incredible with video yeah we believe by
one of the first zone I've never seen it
before today's conference went really
well we had a lot of interest in our
technology we had a lot of connections
lots of business cards and lots of
requests for follow-up meetings
janosh looks set to be kept busy chasing
down leads following up contacts and
sniffing out fresh opportunities this
may be the age of the entrepreneur but
for many it's a thankless task a life of
sacrifice and worry with the odds
stacked heavily against them I'm hoping
this technology will be the platform for
me to realize you know the next stages
in my big dreams which I'm not going to
tell you about because they're my little
secret they'll need more than
inspiration and hard graft a good deal
of luck could make the difference
between surviving and thriving in the
hub
[Music]
[Music]
you
you